[Musique]
alors bonjour à la planète c'est
l'équipe de tam-tam canada qui en direct
de montréal 11 ans 11 vendredi accueil
tout le monde a bien voulu participer à
cette émission notamment du côté de
cette caméra du côté de cette caméra se
trouve on a plusieurs de ces caméras se
trouvent nos copains ici de la section
française de radio-canada on commence
par ismaël bonjour ismaël jour bonjour
stéphane ismaël qui est toujours présent
quand il le peut ah oui bonjour et mans
stéphane bon joueur vraiment aussi
qu'ils acceptaient la commande
aujourd'hui de venir à l'émission je dis
c'est pas une obligation c'est un c'est
une faveur comme une fête quand vous
venez vous vous partagez votre science
ou méconnaissance et ceux qui sont
obligés d'être là et c'est l'émission
marie-claude bonjour marc léo gimeno
également bonjour c'est no 2 way maistre
est du côté de la technique son
traditionnel on retrouve pierre bonjour
pierre
félicitations à ce qu'on voit pierre ce
qui est possible de voir pierre avec
cette voie
et ça c'est pierre ou caro
oui il y en a un autre les 12e on les
voit pas
il ya un pier dutil qui cachaient dans
la noirceur un peu comme l'éminence
grise
il aurait dû être papa mais qui était
celui le caviezel le roi je vous tiens
d'ailleurs qu'on a un surnom fantastique
pour lui
pierre l'utile c'est vrai c'est gentil
ça va passer à l'histoire j'en suis sûre
david histoire de l'analyse on va parler
t aujourd'hui vous connaissez la
tradition un vidéo 5 images vous devez
me dire en cinq images et un peu plus de
seconde
quel est le sujet démission aujourd'hui
dont on va traiter tous ensemble top
euros tout le monde joue à la maison
également et au bureau si vous ne
regardez au bureau de félicitations
prendre aussi près que c'est bon
première image
donc cette mine à ciel ouvert ça c'est
de l'amiante ont pas cessé de l'amiante
voilà pour mâles kohler et près de
l'amiante il s'est affalé est-ce que ça
c'est de l'amiante
ça peut être des du béton amiante c'est
une btan d'amiante
bon j'en connaissais déjà
qu'est ce que c'est que ça maintenant il
ya le mot assure ces sacs sont tellement
il a visé juste
1 une chance qu'on l'avait mission
d'amiens ben oui c'est regarder or la
réponse qui suit est passé que ce petit
masque est suffisant pour vous protéger
du tout pas du tout bien sûr que c'est
ce qu'on a donné encore récemment des
employés qui travaillaient par exemple
dans des hôpitaux qui venait réparer des
tuyauteries et encore beaucoup
d'édifices qui sont isolées protégé par
cette amiante parce qu'on connaissait
pendant de nombreuses années sa valeur
initiale - résistance à la chaleur c'est
ça et où feu parce que t on faire le
tour de table voir si vous êtes en
danger parce que c'est un but mais c'est
un sujet sérieux moi plus j'ai creusé la
sphère ces semaines plus je suis devenu
occupée pour la santé tout le monde
c'est très très sérieux
écoutez est-ce que vous habitez dans un
édifice qui a qui est plus récents ou
plus pluvieux 1990 ce nom plus récent
plus récemment pas de problème voulue
plus vieux qu'elle années 80 mais il y
en a pas les vérifications et effacé
dray bravo félicitations
puis quand vous avez fait des
rénovations récemment ou s'il n'avait
pas pas du tout vous marie-claude moi
c'est un édifice très ancien mais qui a
été converti en condos en 2008 alors je
m'assure que pas d'amiante à dans vos
supposer qu'ils l'ont enlevé selon le
médecin de ville
am 1 72 alors je sais pas on n'a pas
fait la les tests ça peut être partout
là-dessus dans l'état des tarides field
dans le plancher dans les murs dans le
plâtre ça pour être partout je n'ai pas
offert par mon travail de frappe mais
quand même c'est préoccupant quand vous
faites des rénovations c'est ce qu'on
recommande à tout le monde fait venir
d'abord un expert je vais vous faire
entendre de ses experts se mettre dans
le bain des missions dans le sujet andry
cléroux tel qu interviewé par les
couples équipe l'année dernière de
découverte à radio canada on écoute
points sont là bien qu'il y en a mis
partout au québec
au moins 50,1 des justes pour les
travaux d'enlèvement d'amiante telbec en
nombre et en os mis dans les écoles y en
eut omis dans les maisons on omis dans
plusieurs produits on a retrouvé un tube
de plancher ne retrouvait aussi dans les
murs de plâtre really les cloisons les
plafonds clubs ont retrouvé de la viande
dans les joints en jeep souci qui était
plus récent beaucoup d'amiante les
alains d'amiante sur la tuyauterie sur
lisa la mécanique qui était fait avec à
base d'amiante du salaire coupe-faim
pour les structures d'acier
c'est juste pour vous montrer le style
de costumes jetables 2 les gones devront
porter à l'intérieur des zones
contaminées
ils vont
des vestiaires flambant nu à vendre
enfiler la combinaison parce qu'à
l'intérieur sont contaminés ils vont
enlever l'amiante il ça se peut qu'eads
est faible sur les autres c'est pour ça
que derrière qui vont prendre une douche
avant de sortir on enlevait ils vont
prendre leur douche puis vont pouvoir
mettre le vêtement de ville
le
[Musique]
e
voilà c'est un extrait seulement la
réalité aujourd'hui et puis une réalité
qu'on a exporté d'un ta main offre est
un grand producteur partout sur la
planète pour ça qu'on a parlé serre et
du canada est en national aujourd'hui on
a eu un en a une empreinte sur le reste
de la planète
au niveau de ce risque pour la santé
voici notre premier jeu de la grosse
boule cette semaine ne me regardez pas
avec des yeux inquiets ça va bien se
passer
vous en faites pas on va appliquer
cependant cette semaine le règlement à
l'oma demain pas le malawi dorénavant
vous connaissez le règlement palomar
j'en ai entendu parler
alors c'est quoi ce règlement là on a
tous en point au départ d'accord et on
les perd au fur et à mesure bon en fait
l'ailé c'est pas le barça des mânes
tenir alors vous ne gagnez plus de
points mais comme ça on est tous gagnés
vous êtes tous gagnent maintenant oui je
m'en vais voici premier jeu vous pouvez
perdre 20 points quelle chance voici on
exploite des mines d'amiante depuis la
fin du 19e siècle au québec par exemple
il y as un tas je vais vous demander
bon ça c'était il ya cent permet
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est aujourd'hui
non en 1977
quel était le principal producteur
exportateur d'amiante dans le monde
la réponse n'est pas si évidente est-ce
que c'était à la russie mais la chine
c'est le brésil ou d aucune de ces
réponses on va commencer par léo zimmer
encline de ses réponses aucune des
réponses très bien et vous verrez si la
russie aucune ne se répondent sans que
ses réponses également aucune de ces
répondants alors qu'elle dépense vous
choisissez 6 et aucun de ses réponses
je sais pas si c'est pas évident
peut-être un petit pays comme pays
capitalistes
différents communiste communiste
d'accord ce pays communiste capital
social est le canada 5 québec
cette québec un petit pays socialistes
en cas ce serait votre réponse et vous
oui c'est le québec qui sait le québec
est la raison vous avez raison tous les
toits vouga vous conservez vos 20 points
et vous perdez 20 points marie-claude
c'est ce qui se passe c'était la
production 77 la canada on n'était plus
qu'à 50 mille tonnes de production ça a
beaucoup chuté très rapidement dans les
années 70 la russie étaient à leur
première avec un million de tonnes ça
vous donne ici une idée des perspectives
il ya une petite carte à vous montrer
des pays où on a interdit aujourd'hui
l'amiante dans les constructions dans
les temps les oeuvres les routes par
exemple dès qu'on veut vraiment voir la
réponse m'a quel pays enfin à 60 faut
peser ce bouton pas nécessaire de faire
plus que ça voilà l'essentiel de
touteleurope.fr oui c'est ça le monde
arabe l'egypte la turquie l'australie
l'afrique du sud et encore des pays qui
l'autorisent c'est ça qui est incroyable
ouais puis de regarder canal va regarder
le canada et n'est pas rouge qui n'est
pas rouge il y lit rouge dans l'hérault
où il est il va être très très très
foncée remarquer au mois de janvier on a
dit qu'on n'en produisait plus de c'est
vrai on veut plus à produire mais ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on autorise encore
son utilisation c'est ça a été décidé il
ya quelques semaines à peine par le
grand fédéral après avoir promis son
interdiction tata en 2016 lors des
élections en fin 2015 et 2016
même au début de l'année en février
dernier on disait qu'on sera en mesure
d'interdire complètement et finalement
si vous êtes dans l'armée canadienne ne
vous sera encore exposés à l'utilisation
de l'amiante dans les véhicules dans les
bateaux dans les navires j'en avais un
spécialiste de la question militaire
ça dépend ça dépend de la taille ça
s'est-il atopique en effet quand vous
dépassez les en mesure archaïques les
sentiers c'est bien navire 6 empires 3
mètres 32e mais très bien pas de réponse
hésitation 10 points de plus 110
anecdote quand j'étais tout petit à
l'école primaire on faisait de les a
placés avec de l'amiante absolument
comme la plasticine je m'en souviens
très bien la texture de l'auto en
argentine avait les petits plaque
pourfendre les toasts bien d'ailleurs
qu'un quand anecdotes historiques aussi
un peu historico politique quand le
premier gouvernement péquiste a été élu
sous rené lévesque en 76 peu de temps
après monsieur lévesque et à aller
présenter un discours devant elle
les grands clubs économique à new york
et l'outil qu'il mettait de l'avant pour
le développement du québec c'est
effectivement l'amiante et s'est par la
suite donc fin des années 70 que ça
commençait à arriver le jeu des fêtes et
sied à la maison radio-canada ça fait
quelques années ils ont vraiment tout
enlevé il ya eu des grands travaux pour
pouvoir sortir toute l'amiante qu'il y
avait ici parce que je crois qu'elle est
à sony de l'amiante est pas dangereuse
c'est les fibres que l'on respire donc
si on touche quelque chose en amiante de
solides c'est pas dangereux mais
d'amiante solide
essentiellement c'est de la fibre et
damien non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est dans l'atmosphère ces cantons par
exemple l'amiante et du béret dans
l'atmosphère pour ça que c'est souvent
les travailleurs dans les bâtiments qui
sont atteints d'un cancer ou encore de
lui mais pas léser les livres d'écoles
privées ou encore pire les lit mineur
oui parce qu'ils respirent l'air dont
les fibres sont en suspension
sauf que vous prenez un bloc d'amiante
et vous fait ça avec votre pouce et vous
avez d'abel assez dans le 16 heures si
vous voulez la faire intervenir un
troisième spécialiste institutions
c'est une tradition d'aller vers les
gens qui sont vraiment les sommités dans
le domaine on le fait à chaque semaine
ces semaines malheureusement notre
invité s'est désisté il y à une heure et
demie est prêt pour des raisons
d'urgence familiale et ça nous faisait
une grosse beaucoup déçu parce qu'il
aurait pu nous parler en détail des
revendications des travailleurs qui
souffrent et mis en cause notamment
l'amiante est à la source de plusieurs
maladies pulmonaires pas seulement d'un
cancer précisément ils auraient pu nous
en parler aussi des difficultés qu'ont
ces travailleurs de réclamer des
compensations
il ya des combats épiques que devant les
tribunaux où le travailleur se retrouve
t d fois trousses tout seul n'est pas
syndiquée et on conteste le fait qu'ils
demandent une indemnité pour des raisons
de ba2 je pense julien terme de
comptable d'épargné salah mais il ya des
histoires et des injustices souvent
injustement jeunes ces questions là m a
été très utilisé au québec
partout dans le monde mais je suis pas
si c'est là les pays au ban fait
l'endroit où était plus utilisé est-ce
qu'il ya plus des cas des maladies
pulmonaires au québec qu'ailleurs pour
de l'amiante
il y en a c'est la première cause de
maladie c'est quoi le terme de maladies
industrielle au québec
première cause si vous allez en france
c'est la deuxième cause
voici la preuve c'est l'étendue de ma
science là dessus mais pas plus de
détails vous demandez l'on peut pas la
voir sur skype ce qui n'est pas
absolument
mais la voici au mois de septembre
dernier on parlait des intérêts connu
les etats-unis avaient annoncé qu'ils
étaient intéressés à promouvoir une
nouvelle exploitation de l'asbestose de
la merde au niveau de certains objets de
l'industrie donc un renouveau de
l'industrie de l'amiante aux états unis
et ce spécialiste se disait mais
finalement c'est une histoire à n'en
plus finir et on n'a pas fini de payer
pendant des générations pour ses visées
commerciales
le voici donc il s'agit du docteur yves
p
viger chercheurs professeurs
spécialistes de renommée internationale
il possède une vaste expérience en
coopérative internationale et vous allez
voir son titre voilà dr yves bonnet qui
son site officiel le togo par exemple la
viande on peut même la beaucoup d'autres
produits
il faut beaucoup beaucoup de presse et
ont justement réintroduire un moment
donné déclaré qu est-ce qu on peut
penser dans la fabrication des fusées
ils ont dans l'espace que peut-être il
ya peut être des endroits où l'amiante
est ici m'a rappelé à table mais non pas
une utilisation un peu comme en
laboratoire le sujet sans crème un
contrôle limité en elles que les
conducteurs d'un homme voudrait bien
c'est qu'on réintroduit tranquillement
la viande de consommation beaucoup plus
court je vends de salif le problème
c'est que partout on essaie de trouver
tout on pouvait en béton avait mis en
évidence flatres donc la plupart des
maisons qu'elles étaient construites
avant les années 80
alors on fait alors c'est un ex us au
mois de septembre avec le docteur yves
panis viger à l'émission alain gravel ça
s'appelle comment une soumission
matinale pierre vous êtes technicienne
c'était l'un des deux le matin qu'avait
le matin et n'a dû sa tante le sens du
vent c'est tellement évident qu'on prie
arrêtez
ce docteur a été président de
l'association des médecins spécialistes
en santé communautaire du québec de 2009
à 2015 c'est qu'elle est une sommité
d'accord je voulais vous demander
monsieur qui avait voyagé partout vous
avez voyagé maman monsieur d'un certain
âge on l'appelle monsieur oui alors vous
avez vous déjà vous êtes déjà rendu à
asbestos
oui on va passer des images pour ceux
qui n'auront jamais la chance d'y aller
parce qu'il a du talent et ranger
asbestos ted friedmann lee blakeley
convoqué tout pays de l'amiante et aux
gains du v ou iv va falloir qu'on
regarde ces images nous provient ce
poison qu'on ne produit plus maintenant
est ce que c'est vrai que la ville
dépendent est essentiellement due de
cette soul un duo de civils tutsis ville
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est que ces
mines la plupart des mines d'amiante de
ce qu'on appelle un aucune piste c'est à
dire c'est ses bonnes mines où on allait
sous le sol on vous creusez un m vous
faites un mètre de large
vous faites de mettre deux mètres de
large donc c'est un c'est ce grand trou
comme ça qui donne sa voix là est
justement quand on trouvait une veine
qui comme parade on était sous quelques
maisons bien on déplaçait les gens ici
la maison était un des plats sablon
brûler la maison et ont continué le
travail de deux mineurs de la mine tout
simplement
et la simple fait de brûler la maison ça
devait libérer un petit peu de cette
fibre mais ça ce que je voulais je lis
fut vous l'avez vu je suis venu et je
nomme suppose avec la guitare au bout du
bras 7 8 ans puis c'est ce qu'on appelle
un open pc ca et les mines à ciel ouvert
voilà exactement il y en a une en corse
à ce que j'ai appris ce matin j'en ai vu
une page up de l'image des manceaux
wikipedia parce que moi je peux aller
là-bas rapidement mais et puis mon il
disait que le simple fait que ce soit à
découvert comme ça et sa propre cause un
problème avec l'érosion c'est que l'a
fait ensuite se libère dans le solaire
c'est que les vins tout simplement donc
la contamination se poursuit ce que dit
pierre qu'ils sont
qui a pas assez de contenu d'amiante
pour l'exploiter mais il ya cette
comptine amiante pour libérer vers l'est
vers l'air on va aller vers le segment
qui s'appelle me yves permettait dans
les clubs dont va retrouver un reportage
qui fait vraiment des marteaux a produit
ben oui en plus de cela monsieur est
l'aîné c'est pas ce pas une vidéo assez
sur le site d'accompagnement des
initiants de cantat voilà on descend des
sondés s'en voit là haut et vous allez
me dire qu'à vous de votre vos
reportages vraiment je vous signale que
le rouge pourrait être votre couleur oui
oui est ce que ça dit le magnésium
pourrait relancer
ça ressemble à ça ok alors occupe dessus
vous avez fait un reportage sur un
projet qui va de l'avant
ça a été annoncé tout à fait récemment
lorsque vous avez fait l'entrevue avec
un chef d'entreprise 2014 wac
alors on en parlait on voulait utiliser
les résidus de cimino pour produire je
ne sais trop quoi et la cci on vient de
donner le feu vert
ouais vous avez une mémoire d'éléphant
vraiment de quoi s'agissait-il
exactement 7 ou faut savoir qui c'est le
docteur qui avait besoin de lunettes
j'avais le thd chimie et physique et
président et chef de la direction
d'allianz magnésium il est l'invité au
micro de raymond depardon
donc voilà c'est parti je suis parti on
écoute brièvement très brièvement prise
alliance magnésium on peut lire des
décennies d'extraction d'amiante
chrysotile au québec ont généré des
millions de tonnes de résidus de
serpentine qui se caractérise par une
teneur moyenne de 23 3% de magnésium
métallique occasions d'affaires mais
d'abord vous trouvez comment docteur
joël fournier est docteur en chimie
physique il est pdg chef de la direction
d'allianz magnésium et cette société va
installer en fait une usine qui servira
à tester cette possibilité de produire
du méthane à partir de des résidus de
serpentine
dans la région d'asbestos au québec il
est notre invité aujourd'hui de te
fournit bonjour c'est quand même assez
assez pointues comme recherche c'est une
région qui parce qu'elle y produisait à
beaucoup de mauvaise presse par les
temps qui courent et depuis quelques
années l'amiante chrysotile tout à fait
beaucoup de production d'amiante
chrysotile faut savoir que le canada a
été un des producteurs principal
d'amiante chrysotile pour des décennies
qui était peut-être un certain moment et
des avantages pourraient peut-être
transformé en une grande opportunité
la méthode de production et un générer
des résidus qui sait avec une
transformation pour prier peut créer des
produits de très haute valeur ajoutée le
magnésium a une grande importance dans
c'est pas moi qui ai fait ça c'est
youtube encore qui c'est c'est une
construction le mondial ça ce n'est pas
parce que toi demain ce qui est bien
c'est qu'on peut réécouter tout ça sont
des problèmes de serveurs comme si
youtube c'est des problèmes du serbe
radio canada qui garantit les choses une
magnésium ça sert à holon patrie pour
les les autos électriques qui notamment
oui donc c'est ça lithium magnésium
entre autres donc c'est ça on pourra
maintenant créer et participer à cette
course de la montée de l'auto électrique
grâce à cette usine dans un seul et sans
parti ou un parti l'autre partie c'est
quoi essentiellement du grand producteur
mondial de terreur la chine sinon bombe
a coûté pour soi va avoir d'autres
détails vous pouvez l'écouter quid nova
se nouent aussi là je m'en a pris assez
et je pensais alors c'est le jeu la
grosse boule convient de points qu'on
peut perdre cette fois ci tu rêves un
peu tu rentres ans et prétendent
évolutif en plus c'est quand je dis
c'est marie-claude a déjà perdu 20
points les ordonner bond à 100 très bien
voici la deuxième deuxième je remets de
la viande par tout ce qu'on dit a
partout dans cette émission alors voici
en 2012 au québec on estimait que la
province comptaient combien de
kilomètres de route à mina t online
contiennent donc de l'amiante un vain
mot ami nate et ça doit être c'est un
verbe ou n'auront sûrement pas quand
même j'ai ami nate et la route géminées
la route d'amiante
alors voici donc en 2012 on a fait une
estimation ne me sort combien on a nos
vies dans nos routes
oh là là combien de kilomètres selon
vous avons-nous si au québec selon
c'était 6 mai de route à mina t est-ce
que c'est à près de 1500 km est ce que
ces bébés près de 15000 km ou est ce que
c'est c'est aucune de ces réponses n'ont
aucune de ces réponses donc une de ses
réponses
aucune de ces réponses ok faites
attention aucune des sages au coeur dit
houston heureusement c'est 1000 5/5
parce que quinze mille kilomètres sans
frais de kilométrage au québec ça ouais
c'est oui mais un robin en route la plus
que ça plus que ça bah oui
alors si vous avez cherché cela fait
bien cinq ans voilà c'est triste bon
mais positionner pas fini ce n'est pas
fini je savais mais c'est sérieux
g je voulais vous vous faire entendre
quelque chose au niveau de jeu peugeot
espère bien qu ça oui c'est un extrait
d'une entrevue d'un dossier de 27 une
préparé par radio canada en 2010 2017 a
très très bien fait
quand je vous dis des choses qui
devraient être disponibles facilement
ailleurs sur le site de radio-canada des
dossiers il a vraiment bien fait et on
fait beaucoup de choses mais il ya des
choses qui sortent de l'ordinaire
il avait fait une série d'entrevues avec
des gens travailleurs qui sont tombés
malades avec des gens du gouvernement
des gens de mon pays une assurance pour
voir quels étaient les obstacles à
travers lesquelles ses employés là où ex
employés devaient maintenant sauter pour
obsédés d'avoir gain de cause au niveau
financier parcours du combattant points
puis des fois de carte parcours d'humour
qui jouent à qui on fait faire des tours
de l'histoire tout à fait ridicule
j'aimerais vous présenter les 27 minutes
parce que moi j'en suis ressorti
j'écoutais ça dans mon auto pas que
pendant que je conduisais mais pendant
que j'étais stationné et j'écoutais ça
j'ai dit mon dieu quel est ce que ça a
ajouté j'ai je me suis je sais que
j'allais parler de ça c'est semaine
l'amiante mais là ça vient encore ajouté
au fait qu'il faut absolument en parler
des dangers à long terme que cela pose
pour la population pendant des
générations à venir
voici donc un extrait j'ai recoupé je
pense ces deux minutes quelque chose de
cette de grands reportages de 27 minutes
réparé par radio-canada en écoutant
lorenzo harvey est mourant mais
l'hôpital exige qu'il se fasse examiner
à nouveau cette fois par le médecin
expert que l'employeur a retenu
l'homme de 82 ans est sommé de se rendre
à montréal à six heures de route de jean
pierre
à la fin il y avait révélé métastases
alors leur son corps était très très
très sensible justin ni police ils
faisaient mal hui on se présente pas au
pied des frais engendrés on doit on est
responsable de ces frais l'ofac l'eau
c'est comme tout bon moi j'ai pas
demandé à les rencontrer ce monsieur là
pour quoi que
il viendrait pour lui me voir pour
prendre quelqu'un si loin qu'attend on
ne plaint de médecins partout l'eau
le docteur paolo lorenzi a l'habitude de
ce genre de côte il a fourni son
expertise pour le compte d'employeurs
dans au moins une quarantaine de
contestation des dénis des reliées à
l'amiante
un examen de la jurisprudence démontre
que les employeurs ont eu gain de cause
trois fois sur quatre dans les bosses et
où il est impliqué ce que peut être la
succession et va pas payer les
expertises nécessaires pour contrer son
expert ce qui m'a dit c'est super et
j'essaie puis ok rallye je vais perdre
mais a de bonnes chances que je puisse
régler hors cour si je peux pas régler a
recours il ya de bonnes chances que
quelqu'un est tombé il ya une bonne
chance peut-être même que je vais gagner
parce que la partie adverse est passée
indiqué où le travailleur n'était pas
syndiqués puis qui a pas de chance qui
va trouver un médecin expert à 1000 2000
3000 4000 d'alain alors ça c'est un
témoignage d'autres des gens qui sont
encore en vie auquel on crée des
difficultés parce que pour beaucoup
d'endroits même des enfants comme des
hôpitaux les endroits où deux ou un des
employeurs
disons qu'ils ne sont pas des employeurs
privés les employeurs publics et pour
eux le problème d'accorder un employé
bon d'accord vous avez droit on
reconnaît qu'avec best-of lorsque vous
faisiez des travaux bien c'est que c'est
la suite mais c'est aussi le présent
c'est ça augmente les coûts d'assurance
pour tous pour toutes les opérations
puisqu'on sait qu'il y avait des
problèmes dont il y en aura d'autres en
ce sens c'est un combat pour les
générations mais pour d'autres formes de
génération une âme à générations de
comptable peut-être que je sais pas moi
je pose pas de jahvé lui que c'est
particulièrement difficile au québec et
au canada parce que celles employées qui
doit poursuivre l'employeur alors que en
europe par exemple en france il ya eu
des c'est l'état qui est émis
responsable qui a accepté d'assumer la
responsabilité tout nouveau tout à fait
oui et donc ça facilite par exemple les
indemnisations ou le reste est donc ici
et peut-être aussi un problème de
responsabilité aussi
je veux bien qu'on nous avait parlé de
la france parce que justement le
reportage de radio-canada en parlait
avec des responsables disent eh oui on a
fini par on a compris c'était une
responsabilité sociale
il faut l'assumer faut que le
gouvernement et que pas ici au québec
s'est encore récemment là il y avait un
gouvernement qui s'appelait celui de
jean charest gouvernement libéral qui
dit ouais écouter frais continue quand
même à voir si on peut pas qu'on
exploite et toujours lamyaghri dans des
conditions plus sécuritaire et le
discours est pas con le monde paru un
pas convaincu tout à fait par rapport à
ça vous êtes prêts pour le dernier jeu
oui c'est pas la fin d'émission ce n'est
que le dernier jeu alors derniers jeux
c'est très sain moi je dis les peler
point là vous devriez pas les perdre
bon la coopération ouais c'est quand la
dernière dans la question d'heures il
n'ya pas perdre ses parents la
concentration mais mon ami louis
dangereux il regarde sa liste d'épicerie
[Rires]
c'est le togo qui tendrait les clients
peut faire deux choses bravo alors je de
la grosse boule troisième marche
combien de points à perdre cinq ans 57 x
environnantes à chaque fois très simple
comme question quel pays est maintenant
le plus grand producteur d'amiante au
monde vous avez un choix de réponses
est ce que c'est à la chine est ce que c
b le chili est ce que c'est c'est le
cambodge au où est-ce que céder aucune
de ces réponses
moi je dirais le chili turine chili
c'est les lithium
moi je traîne de ses réponses le chili
dont celle dite yam
ouais ouais donc ça pourrait le césium
oui c'est lié ouais ouais donc ça rien
fils on le sait plus amer c'est plus un
indice mais vous pouvez le choix seat
chine mais chili c'est cambodge d aucune
de ces réponses
sinon schwabing juste inquiets aucune ne
sert aucune merci réponse de quelle
machine il inflige je garde je garde un
sens c'est une bonne réponse
potentiellement potentiel quel serait
votre bonne réponse par vous pensez vous
beaucoup de choses et vous marie-claude
gto qu'elle ne se répand aucune de ces
réponses
alors ces réserves est attendue aucune
de ces réponses vous garder vos 50 vous
c'était la russie salue ces cas perdu 0
non non non vous avez perdu
j'aimerais tout point vous marie-claude
vous avez du premier je vous avais pas
eu 58 donc perdu 35 ans peut-être oui
marie claude il lui restait 50
ouais bon ça veut dire que vous en reste
50 oui très bon on peut sans fin de 60
vous une idée lui ça vole à 70 la
première était correcte la gagnante est
correct c'est 50 70 c soit vous remercie
beaucoup dit que c'est compliqué
règlement à l'oma et vous sait combien
il reste 20 plus belles points donc
notre champion avec la couronne sétif
j'ai géré at que je puisse amener sa de
la maison j'y travaille c'est une petite
couronne que s'allume dernière vous ça
monte derrière votre dos est ensuite
savez comment on appelle ça un ami à la
définition c'est quoi c'est quelqu'un
qui vous connaît pas qui vous aime quand
même beaucoup dans votre cas c'est bien
placé on est prêt pour le la vidéo où
l'image de la semaine c'est dans ce cas
c'est les deux alors je voici comment ça
fonctionne je vous dis pas je répond par
oui ou par non
c'est tout ce que je peux faire faut pas
que ça dure trop longtemps sinon on va
s'ennuyer et vous devez déterminer
quelle est l'image ou la vidéo de la
semaine cette semaine au canada
alors regardez pas l'écran vous pouvez
pas vous pouvez pas participer baricco
je l'avais pas encore pas encore ok
d'accord mais on fait jouer la musique
car c'est le suspense voici quelle est
l'image de la semaine
aucun indice n'a au canada au canada ça
lui donne un disque l'image de la
semaine au canada
le drapeau franco ontarien n'y est pas
ça aurait pu l oui oui c'est vrai combat
des francos intervenir entre le
gouvernement de l'ontario qui a
s'imbrique dans les services non c'est
pas le cas ça aurait pu l'hiver un mode
avance ça c'est au cas au québec maurice
canada québec l'ontario où les toits des
promesses maritime friday
ça aurait pu être sa aujourd'hui black
friday mais non 1
nord alors qu'est-ce que je suis minéral
végétal ou artisanale minier mignon est
ce végétal non général à m balès humain
animal qui aime beaucoup les humains
donc l'histoire du football
pas un chien mais achats pas un chat
loiseau apparu qui nous aiment pas un
oiseau du tout qui nous aiment
un animal qui nous aiment bat yam qui
aime beaucoup être au contact des êtres
humains
une vache pas du tout fait ça quoique
williams canton l'économie allait aussi
tellement proches pas le chien par le
chant des oiseaux
mais non mais non ça marche dans la
neige pas dans le sable toujours pas
d'ours pas cette fois ci passer de nous
pas de loup non plus un jour peut-être
pas me revois cette semaine pas d'eau
rien non plus je ne l'atteint pas de la
paix c'est très joli rhmani nous est un
animal sauvage déjà par la démission
l'année on en a fait une émission
spéciale c'est le cas alors c'est facile
quel contexte de coyah si on regarde
facile imsa c'est la vidéo on avait les
images nous avons regardé la vidéo on ne
joue pas avec un coup de jeune dans
l'alberta qui s'attaque à un colloque on
sache de façon inhumaine voilà c'est
très dur à regarder si vous êtes au
québec je pense que vous n'avez pas vu
ces images m'ont tout l'ouest canadien
parle du caractère inhumain les
policiers pensent connaître les deux
jeunes qui sont à l'origine de ce crime
là il ya des façons humaines des façon
inhumaine de traiter les animaux
moi ça m'a affecté parce qu'on a
traitées on a parlé des coyotes
il ya un mois et demi et les gens
peuvent retourner sur notre émission
spéciale où on parle du contact des
coyotes au haut des eaux par rapport aux
citadins de plus en plus il ya cette
interaction et que c'est vraiment pas
décent des bêtes dangereuses
on peut les
désormais c'est pas comme un loup c'est
pas aussi agressif hier on avait
beaucoup de détails dans cette émission
le spécialiste et puis moi ça va j'ai
regardé ça c'est moi ça vraiment pas
comprendre des animaux de cette façon là
que ce soit un chat un chien ou encore
je comprends pas ces animaux les animaux
qui vous fait que les policiers sur la
piste et puis la société protectrice des
animaux également alors on ne sait pas
encore s'il va y avoir des accusations
déposées et c'était sur youtube
c'est d'abord ça passe a passé sur
facebook on sait se retrouver sur
youtube et c'est surtout la chaîne ctv
et si oui si qui ont diffusé ces images
peuvent choquer
donc c'est les jeunes eux mêmes qui
avaient d'abord me salir et c'est pas la
première fois il ya une autre histoire
de crime cette semaine dans un
établissement scolaire à toronto où les
jeunes ont également filmer des scènes
de violence sur d'autres ou plus au plan
sexuel dont que c'est on commet un crime
et en films en même temps une fois de
cette semaine et ou aux états unis un
dauphin retrouvé sur la plage assassiné
par balles ils recherchaient des auteurs
de ce crime ce qui le dauphin avait dû
nous être naufragés sur la plage puis il
a été assassiné ce qui reviendrait aussi
un mode l'homme il ya de l'hommerie moi
je vais pas vous laisser là dessus mais
je pense que ça va être le cas
aujourd'hui
ce que je peux faire une suggestion à
louis balling couronne si on gagne ce
qu'on pourra voir une corne de licorne
lumineuse
j'en avais donc j'aimerais juste vous
rappeler que le cannabis légal
[Rires]
aussi il faut se rappeler qu'il faut pas
fumer avant de venir travailler
c'est un autre conte c'est surtout si
vous comptiez mission merci beaucoup
avait claude ok mais très bonne
situation qui sortent du studio pour sa
part
salut mon cher puis vous vous retournez
au travail parce que c'est que vous
voulez oui et oui faut retourner ouzou
s'est déjà préparé de tabac les jumelles
ont merci beaucoup
prochaine tout le monde merci